This week. I got a call from my good friend, Jim,
and he's dealing with an issue that a lot of men are dealing with. You know,
man, don't you, you see them out there in the morning,
drink and wine beaten each other.
So like any good friend I hopped in an Uber select and went to pick him up to
see what was.
There you go, man. Good, welcome.
So what's been going on with you? Well, yeah,
I've been doing stand-up now for 15 years,
for the first say 12 years.
I did a lot of misogynistic jokes and I feel now with the good ones. Yeah,
man. And I always thought that people understood that I was joking.
So they were in on the character.
But now I feel like a lot of people took them more seriously or laughing for the
wrong reasons, but I've definitely toned it down a bit,
but I'd like some help with my material.
Yeah. That's what I was thinking is like,
I've been dealing with a lot of the same stuff, you know,
I don't even know what's going on anymore. Like,
I'm almost afraid to even have a Dick.
Anymore. What's wrong with your Dick? And I was just.
Like, it feels like I have a weapon. It's like,
I leave the house with like a knife that's made out of like Dick meters.
You know? It's like a, not even a, it just feels dangerous. But look, man,
I'm just as scared as anybody right now. It's like, I'm just,
I don't know if it's okay to be a man. I don't know if it's okay to wear it.
Do you feel like being masculine is being taken away?
I always thought that women like that, man, he takes control confidence in,
in Sweden. Now you have to ask to change positions during sex. Oh really? Yeah.
You go, I'm going to change position now. Are you okay with that?
You can't just be someone flipping my eyes. Cause then yeah. That's my move
is the flip.
So Jim has a lot of questions about how men are supposed to act in this day and
age.
And especially also how we as comedians are supposed to entertain so that we
are not offending people like on purpose. Maybe. I don't know. That's the thing.
I don't know.
So who better to answer our questions about the opposite sex than someone who's
both a comedian and a feminist.
This is like a group of girls that I meet up with. They're like,
bad-ass like gangsters, like independent women, like feminist,
but not like too hardcore. Okay. Okay.
Cause you guys are trying to like understand what you can say.
Yeah. We were afraid to get out of the car. Yeah.
And they, they want to learn too. They want to learn from you guys.
What you guys are sharp. Good, good.
I like your body.
So Whitney has been my friend for a long time.
And today she has a group meetup that Jim and I can learn from.
And I trust.
Well, a lot of my girlfriends are trepidatious.
They feel like they can't make jokes. They don't want to offend anyone.
They want to upset anyone. If you and I go do a spot at the comedy store, same,
we both do 20 minutes. Do you think we should get paid the same amount? Yes.
Then you're a feminist.
I feel like there are feminists out there that give out other feminists a bad
name.
Because there are a lot of women that think feminists,
but they're actually just.
And we're in this climate where women can't even call out other women or people
freak out and you're slut-shaming and you're fighting and it's a really
unhealthy dynamic. Okay. So Theo, like what's your biggest fear?
Um, probably fire mostly.
I mean, within the context of all the me too stuff.
And do you feel like you are comfortable going on stage with the material we've
talked? Is there stuff you guys want to talk through?
I did a Valentine's day joke that does the rounds every year. Uh,
all Valentine's day is a mathematical equation that every man has in his
head. And it's how much money do I have to spend so that you won't act like a.
Yeah. But see, that's funny to me.
Here's why that's funny to me. I don't think you're talking about me. Yeah.
I just go Jim dates dummy.
That joke was about all women.
I thought that these feminists were going to be super angry.
I thought they were going to have little like knives that were like carved out a
bone out of man bone. But I thought that these ladies were very accepting.
I didn't feel like that they were angry.
They just wanted to make sure that they were heard.
And there's like two sides of the meat tube of it. For men, you can be on the,
like on the bad guy side, which is like Harvey Weinstein and bill Cosby.
Or you can be like the heroes of this and like be the dudes that are like, Hey,
how can I support you women? What can I do that will make you feel more safe?
Or like, what joke can I tell that will be supportive. Right?
Normalize the word continent America more than probably anyone has.
It's another swear word.
Well, yeah. I mean, I have a problem with the C word.
Arkansas. You, you just tell me man, put up your hands,
you do the sentence and then I'll go. And.
Then.
Somebody puts you a dream catcher. Would you like that?
No. What about a God splitting the bill with you?
We actually offer. And I've talked about this all the time. I think you should.
Yeah, but they get the purse up. They're very quick to put it back away.
I have paid for three trips to Thailand. Oh wow.
That was the surgery. [inaudible].
Yeah. I mean, I really appreciate you guys this time. I think, you know,
I'm not afraid to talk to feminists.
I feel less nervous than when I came in here, Jim.
I also feel less nervous.
These women are a lot more supportive than I thought they would be.
And when somebody lets you share your thoughts and really listens to those,
it really makes it a lot easier for you to hear theirs.
I want to invite you to.
Feminist art show it's Ivanka or the performance artists is one
woman shows. Yeah. We'll we'll come to it. Um, would you do a set for us?
Um, yeah
[inaudible] thank you.
[inaudible].
Look, Jim is a very smart man.
Probably one of the six or seven or 30,000, maybe third,
fifth to 18,000, a smartest man around and from this experience,
he will develop an educated perspective because that's what he does with all
experiences. And that's what good comedians do.
Hi my mom. This is my,
my choice,
my, my, my, my, my, my, my.
My is not a rap song for you to rap about skate is mine and mine only.
It's definitely.
Unique environment here.
And if you want to be in less fear of a group like feminists.
Spend some time with them, not just,
I scream the history of sadness so that we all can chat together.
[inaudible].
You know,
I felt honored that they invited us and I was even more surprised at how
accepting they were of me being able to share my thoughts. Thank you.
We're going to give you a hug.
Of course I consent.
So no sex.
I tried to write a poem and I am pretty nervous. Uh, but I will do my best.
My Wiener is chill, man. It ain't trying to do no crime.
It ain't even that hard. A lot of the time. And that's true actually,
because a lot of times I'll get like those Wiener pills from the gas station.
You know what I'm talking about them real giraffe makers, you know,
make my legs, sweat. Actually, my Wiener is trill. My Wiener is candid.
It looks like Joe Peshy. It's that wet bandit.
But I'm lit to the fact that girls are far more than sex.
They are champions and soldiers with power in their breasts.
They are creative and equal and warm and life bringing.
I love Dolly Parton, but it's because of her singing.
My Wiener is chill, man. It ain't trying to do crime. It ain't even that hard.
A lot of the time, my Wiener ain't Weinstein. My Wiener ain't Cosby,
but sometimes it wishes for a little bit of a Jasmine. You feel me?
[Inaudible].
Uh, poems called, uh, things I thought of today.
Oh, I'm a main sort of, and I try to do right, like Rosario,
Donald taking a small bite. She's a big girl. Cut.
It's so confusing to know what to think and what to say.
If only I wasn't an atheist, at least I could pray. Okay.
Uh, I use women for sex and some have used me.
Like you seem depressed.
Except you sit when you.
Pee and you can't spill women without men and there's no men
without women. So I guess at the end of the day, we're all just pieces of.
So I don't dislike feminists or I don't dislike feminist.
I just don't want to hear their poetry.
There were moments that I enjoyed and there were moments that I had also fear,
but at least we learned something, you know.
We didn't, I think I learned a little bit during the day with the group.
I think they became more accepting. You became more general.
I became more accepting and then the poetry ruined it all.
And now I'm back to where I started. I'll say this. I learned that they.
Laugh at a lot more stuff than I thought they would.
I didn't think that they would laugh at anything, but I wasn't. I, I think they,
most of them were seem pretty. I don't even know.
I'm done with the hearing that sentence.
Yeah. Today was a really good day. I got to take one of my heroes into,
you know, snatch Ghana, Stan,
and really see what was going on with some feminists. And in the end,
I think we both learned some stuff. We learned that some feminists are cool.
It takes a lot of fabric and extra textiles to make one of those with Justin
and three, I really like Uber select and then I'll tip my driver the same,
whether they're male or female.
Can I have permission to hug?
Good evening, good afternoon. And other times. Thanks for watching that video.
You just saw. I mean, it was okay, but the next video you could watch,
it could be way better.
What if you watch a video right now that changes your life where you could watch
this one. Ah,